a haze blankets the streets of pekanbaru
city on the island of Sumatra fires have
been burning here in Riau province for
more than a month many started
deliberately by farmers and plantation
companies to clear land for planting
most of the haze is smoke rising from
this land which is flammable peat below
the surface while it looks like the
fires have been put out there
smouldering underground firefighters are
trying to contain the spread but the
annual dry season is making things even
more difficult forced to find water
wherever they can
from creeks rivers and lakes although
schools have been closed for more than a
week market traders in Rio are open but
say the choking haze is bad for business
I'm worried we can't breathe we want a
solution to this problem I wanted to
stop happening every year and it's
causing breathing problems hospitals are
filled with a growing number of patients
I've seen an increase in the number of
patients 30 percent of them have acute
respiratory infections some have asthma
and pneumonia protesters have taken
their frustrations to the governor's
office we want the companies responsible
for the fires to be punished and find a
solution to stop the haze the government
should let volunteers help with
firefighting efforts we also want the
heads of police and the military to step
down president Joko Widodo stressed that
fire prevention is essential he's
calling on the local government to take
more responsibility by boosting
reinforcements of firefighters and
increasing cloud seeding operations to
induce rain we will find out if this is
intentionally organized or just
sporadically done by local people to
open a farm but seeing the massive area
affected we believe it's organized and
thick smog has crossed borders into
Malaysia and Singapore causing
diplomatic disputes with both